>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Everyone, thank you for coming.
I'm just going to lift
this up a little bit.
Happy Halloween, first of all.
But more importantly,
Happy Founders Day Weekend.
My name is Cait Miller, and I'm
a music reference librarian here
in the Music Division, and with
Founders Day happening this year
on a Friday night, we've been
lucky enough to kind of extend it
into a whole weekend of activities,
featuring both Meredith Monk
and her ensemble last night, which
I hope some of you were here for,
and today's performance
of music by Pomerium,
which will be very fun
happening this afternoon.
But the fun thing this year
is that the celebration
of Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge
goes beyond two days even.
We're celebrating it all the
way through the end of January,
and that's because of the Music
Division's current exhibit
on display in the performing arts
reading room across the street.
If you haven't been yet, it's on the
first floor of the Madison Building.
Just walk across the street.
It's worth the little walk.
It's called Chamber Music
, the Life and Legacy
of Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge.
I'm up here speaking to you right
now because I was lucky enough
to get to co-curate the
exhibit along with Robin Rausch,
another music reference librarian,
who is going to join me
up here in a little bit.
But when we talked about what we --
I mean, so it seemed perfect, right,
that we would do some sort of
pre-concert lecture this weekend,
and Robin and I talked about it
would be fun to do a little talk
about sort of the difficulty of
taking such a great, impressive life
and condensing it into an exhibit
where we could only feature
about 50 pieces and trying
to decide what we would show
and what we couldn't
fit into the exhibit.
So when we found out about it and
we started mapping out our plan,
Robin and I did discover a
short documentary had been made
in the '90s about Mrs. Coolidge, and
we knew right away after watching it
that we had to feature it in the
exhibit somehow, and it became sort
of the centerpiece of the
exhibit across the street.
We got in contact with the
filmmaker, Marjorie Short,
and we're so happy that, A, she
let us use the documentary, B,
that she was willing to let us
put it in the online exhibit,
which is on the Library's website
so that everybody can enjoy
it wherever you are, and, C,
we're so happy that she was able to
join us today, and she's also going
to be joining in a
conversation in a few minutes.
[ Applause ]
So we're going to show
the video because --
has anyone seen the video yet?
It's been playing -- was
playing last night, and -- great.
So most of you haven't.
So we need to show
it, and that's great.
But first, I just wanted to give
you a little bit more information
about Marjorie and how
she came to join us today.
Marjorie Short is an Academy
Award nominated producer,
director, and writer.
She studied literature and drama at
Trinity College, Oxford University,
studied film at the legendary Orson
Wells Film School in Cambridge,
and has an MS in film from
Boston University's School
of Communication.
She's a graduate of the AFI
Conservatory's Directing Program.
Her short documentary, Kudzu, was
nominated for an Academy Award
in 1977, won 13 awards, and was
screened at numerous film festivals,
including Cannes and the
New York Film Festival.
With over 30 years' experience,
Marjorie has worked extensively
in Boston, Hollywood,
and Washington, D.C.,
and she has credits in
television, commercials,
award-winning corporate films,
documentaries, and features.
In 1995, Marjorie was looking
for work in Washington, D.C.,
and she was doing research
at the Library of Congress
for a new project on
historical music performance.
One of our music librarians,
actually Ray White,
whom many of you know, suggested
that she contact a woman
named Cyrilla Barr.
Cyrilla was a professor of
musicology at Catholic University,
and she was ten years
into a biography
of Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge
at the time, the great patron
of chamber music, who we're
celebrating this weekend.
Marjorie had never heard of
Mrs. Coolidge at that point,
but she was captivated by her
story, especially when she learned
that Coolidge had commissioned
Aaron Copland's much-loved ballet
from Martha Graham,
"Appalachian Spring".
Cyrilla Barr enjoyed the
support of the Music Division --
of then Music Division
Chief John Newsome,
who believed in the
importance of Coolidge's story
and wanted it to be told.
She arranged for Marjorie
to meet John Newsome,
and all three discussed
the possibility
of a documentary film
on Mrs. Coolidge.
Newsome commissioned
Marjorie to write --
to create an eight-minute
documentary promotional video
and a proposal and budget
for an hour-long documentary
on Mrs. Coolidge's life and legacy.
The brief biopic was
completed in 1996,
and a longer documentary
still awaits funding.
So we're going to play the
film now, and after the film,
Robin and Marjorie are going to
come up here and have a conversation
about the difficulty of
whittling down such a great life
to an eight-minute video
or a 50-piece exhibit.
So let's watch.
[ Music ]
>> Appalachian Spring, considered
one of the greatest works
of 20th Century American Music.
Its premier catapulted
composer Aaron Copland
and choreographer Martha
Graham to fame.
This magnificent treasure, among
many others, would not exist
without the greatest benefactor
of chamber music in our time,
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge.
Who was this complex, extraordinary
woman, and what led her
to become what some call
the great lady of music?
[ Music ]
Born to Nancy and Alfred
Sprague in 1864, Elizabeth grew
up on Chicago's prosperous
Gold Coast
in a family whose fortune was made
in the wholesale grocery business.
She was a cherished child,
whose parents firmly believed
in fiscal responsibility and using
one's wealth to support the arts.
Her childhood was spent
surrounded by music and musicians.
She studied piano with Regina
Watson, who was herself taught
by a protege of Franz Liszt.
[ Music ]
Young Elizabeth performed
in recitals and longed
for a professional music career.
[ Music ]
But she was an upper
class Victorian girl,
and such a public life
was out of the question.
[ Music ]
Music remained her passionate hobby
as her parents groomed
her for marriage.
Elizabeth was 24 when
she met and fell in love
with Frederick Shurtleff
Coolidge, a Harvard graduate
and orthopedic surgeon from
a prominent Boston family.
[ Music ]
In 1891 at the age of 26,
Elizabeth married Fred in a wedding
that was the social event
of the Chicago season.
[ Music ]
In 1894, the birth of their son,
Sprague, added to their happiness.
The Coolidge family seemed blessed,
but their joy was short-lived.
[ Music ]
A year later, Fred cut himself
during orthopedic surgery
on a syphilitic patient and became
infected with the dread disease.
He also contracted tuberculosis
and suffered multiple strokes.
For 20 years, Fred submitted bravely
to harsh treatments at clinic
after clinic, as the family
frantically sought the latest cure.
[ Music ]
For 20 years, Elizabeth experienced
the heartbreak of losing the love
of her life inch by inch.
[ Music ]
As an added blow and an
especially cruel one,
Elizabeth began to lose her hearing.
Ignoring her disability, she
immersed herself in music,
which provided her only solace
throughout Fred's illness.
She performed privately with small
ensembles, studied music composition
with respected tutors, and opened
a music school at Upway Fields,
her Pittsfield, Massachusetts home.
And then the darkest
period of her life began.
Between January 1915 and March
1916, Elizabeth lost her father,
her mother, and her husband.
What should have been a joyful
event, her son's spring graduation
from Harvard and his marriage,
resulted in Elizabeth being
left completely alone.
She was 52 years old and no one
would have questioned her right
to retreat back behind the
walls of her home and greave.
But Elizabeth Sprague
Coolidge was a survivor.
Following the example set by her
parents, Elizabeth took control
of the Sprague fortune,
estimated to be between three
and four million dollars.
One week after her father's death,
she set up a $100,000 pension fund
for the Chicago Symphony
Orchestra in his name and matched
that gift after her mother died.
Then she donated the family
homes and money to philanthropic
and educational adventures.
All as memorials to her
beloved parents and husband.
Because music had sustained
her throughout adversity,
Elizabeth devoted every day
of her remaining 37 years
to repaying that debt.
It became her personal mission
to support music and musicians,
building musicians living quarters,
founding the Berkshire Quartet,
organizing the first Berkshire
Festival, a competitive arena
for music composition, initiating
live radio broadcasts, free lectures
and music recitals at libraries
and universities throughout
the US and Europe.
To ensure that her work would
survive after her death,
Elizabeth perused a unique alliance
with the federal government.
It took an act of Congress
but she prevailed.
Establishing the Coolidge foundation
at the Library of Congress
and building the Coolidge
Auditorium there.
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge supported
countless musicians and composers.
[ Music ]
Hundreds of important compositions
exist because of her conviction
that all styles of
chamber music must be heard
by as many people as possible.
[ Music ]
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge
transformed a modest fortune
into a lasting endowment.
More than that, perhaps,
was her ability
to transform tragedy into triumph.
And her vision and determination
transformed silence into language
that needs no translation.
[ Music ]
>> Good afternoon.
I am Robin Rouche, a music reference
specialist in the music division
at the Library of Congress
and it's my great pleasure
to finally get to meat
Margery Short.
The film maker whose film
has been leaving people tears
over in our reading room.
Welcome. I wanted to start today by
talking about the biographers craft
because both your film
as well as Kate's
and my exhibit are
forms of biography.
And the challenges that came
with doing a very short
telling of a life.
Your film was eight minutes,
our exhibit was a little
under 50 items, I think.
And how you are -- are able to tell
a story in such a confined way.
Biographers are -- what do I want
to say -- the art of biography.
It's your subject's life
but it's your story.
You're the one who is
selecting what stories
to tell and what to leave out.
So, tell us a little bit
about telling the life
of Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge.
>> Well, I, first of
all, owe everything
to Cyrilla Barr, who
is the biographer.
Who spent, all told, 14 years
researching Mrs. Coolidge's life
here at the Library of Congress
and also went to Europe and all
over the US to meat and interview
people that she had worked
with in the past and
research and archives there.
So, Cyrilla -- It was a -- it was
a challenge because, first of all,
John Newsome wanted this film
to be made about Mrs. Coolidge.
So, we started with the eight
and a half minute video.
And so, Cyrilla and I had to look at
what where the most important things
about Mrs. Coolidge that
we want the world to know.
If you knew nothing about
her, which I knew --
I was in that position when I --
Cyrilla told me about Mrs. Coolidge
and this book that she
had been researching.
So, we still trying to find the most
important things that, you know,
she experienced was a challenge.
It was a real discipline.
We came up with a skeleton
outline covering the major points.
You know, came up, where she was
from, her parents, her background,
her love of music and we built
from there but we also knew
that this was going to be a video
and that we would need images.
So, we spent weeks at the art --
at the Coolidge collection across
the street looking through boxes
without white cotton gloves
on and with the help of one
of our retired -- what's his title?
Kevin? Is his title?
>> Kevin Lavine.
He was a music reference specialist.
>> A music reference specialist.
So Kevin was our guide
and we would --
were looking for image that we
could use in this little video.
So we were, unlike your challenge of
having objects, we had to use things
that could be photographed
-- could be filmed.
Either they were already photographs
or they were music manuscripts
or they were other
objects like music programs
and whatever; letters, documents.
We spent that time
researching, looking not just
for the short documentary
but for the long documentary.
And we found things that
hadn't been cataloged yet.
They were -- it was
like found objects.
It was like "OH my god, look at
this!", and in the process of,
you know, doing this, Mrs.
Coolidge came to life.
It was like the real
flesh and blood person.
The real living person and her
real relationship with her parents,
especially her mother, who was such
an important character in her life
and her parents and the wonderful
home and the great background
that she had through them.
So he was looking for the story,
looking for how can we communicate
this and so we came up with a script
as well, and I actually worked
with a writer on the script.
That was very challenging.
That's where the rubber
really met the road.
We're -- okay, have an x number of
minutes, so it's a minute per page.
So we have only so many words
we can put into this script,
and each phrase had to be
anchored to something visual.
So it was challenging.
And then -- but this -- but in
our case, I think the discipline
of having that really very
constricted timeframe helped us.
It was like writing a short story,
as opposed to writing a novel.
And people frequently say that
short story writing is the most
challenging of writing
forms because you have
to squeeze a lot into a small space.
The other thing is that I
knew that with the budget --
the actual budget for this, the
production portion of it was $7500,
which doesn't cover much.
That does not cover much.
John Newsome actually -- the whole
commission was much more than that,
but the rest of it had to go to
pay me for my time and the effort
and the work on creating a proposal
for the hour-long documentary
and the budget.
So I was thinking, well, how
am I going to construct this?
So I felt that "Appalachian
Spring" was her most famous,
well-known work.
She commissioned hundreds of works,
but that was the one that was --
that drew me to the project.
And so, I decided to use the
music from "Appalachian Spring"
as the soundtrack of this video.
And so, I had to listen to it
many times -- am I -- good --
and come up with sections
that would work.
So that was really time consuming
and took -- that was very difficult.
But that to me was, you know, the --
what I thought would draw people in,
into this, into her story.
So I think it's just, in
summary, you have to kind
of know what your parameters
are and what your audience is,
and then you just have to whittle
away at everything until you get it
down to something that works
and something that fits.
>> And I think using
"Appalachian Spring"
as the anchor was really a brilliant
idea because most people don't know
who Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge is,
which is a challenge unto itself.
But they do know what
"Appalachian Spring" is.
So that worked really well.
But you also used other
musical examples too,
and the way that you segued from
one to the other was just seamless.
Talk a little bit about how you
selected what other musical examples
to use in this.
>> I think, as I remember back,
Cyrilla was really important
in that decision process.
She's a musicologist, and
we -- she knew, of course,
Mrs. Coolidge's commissions, you
know, backwards and forwards,
upside down and inside out.
And she also knew what they all
sounded like, what all the works --
she pretty much had seen
all the manuscripts.
So we kind of wanted to show a
variety of different styles of music
because Mrs. Coolidge believed that
all types of music should be heard,
and it -- she didn't
limit her commissions
to her own personal taste.
She was very committed
to contemporary music
that at the time was considered
contemporary music, Hindemith
and Poulenc and all the other,
you know, composers that we chose.
So we chose a mixture of
people from the spectrum
of her commissioning
work, and of course --
and then with "Appalachian Spring",
but we wanted to have
a variety of sounds.
So I think we discussed
which pieces she thought --
Cyrilla thought would be
appropriate to consider.
And then we listened to
them, and then we picked --
actually, we tended to
pick the section that was
at the beginning of the manuscripts.
So the manuscripts we also hunted
for in the Coolidge collection,
and that was an amazing thing too,
to see the actual handwritten,
sometimes cut and pasted
manuscripts.
There they were.
It was amazing.
So what I wanted to do most --
I think mostly from what I remember
is we picked the opening theme
of each piece.
And so, when the camera panned
across the musical staff,
you're hearing what's written.
So then the editing process took,
you know, place, where you --
we faded into -- from one to the
other and also did cross fades
with the musical scores, just
to kind of give a feeling
of [excited noises] so much
music, oh, my God, oh, my God.
And even if you can't, like,
read the names of the composers
or see their photos,
it was like layers.
It was layers.
That was to give you the
feeling of how much there was,
and you were only seeing just
a few of the many hundreds.
So it was a combination of
coming up with variety and things
that would work well with
each other that could segue,
that wouldn't be abrupt and just,
you know, unpleasant to listen to.
>> Okay. I know one of the
manuscripts that's in the exhibit
across the street is George Crumb's
"Ancient Voices of Children",
which was written in
1970, which was long
after Mrs. Coolidge had
already passed away.
But it's been very amusing that
people are fascinated by the white
out on that manuscript because
white out is like so retro nowadays.
>> Yeah.
>> So I know you aspire to continue
with your longer documentary
about Mrs. Coolidge and that you
have conducted some interviews
with other people who were --
who either knew her or
were influenced by her.
You want to talk a
little bit about that?
>> Sure. Okay.
The first one was the
widow, then living widow
of the French composer
Darius Milhaud.
You've probably -- probably
not familiar with his name,
but he was a part of
a group in Paris in --
at the early years of the 20th
century called Les Six, The Six.
And they were kind of
rebels and rabble rousers,
and they kind of shook up
the French music scene.
And he was a Jewish composer, and
Mrs. Coolidge commissioned a number
of works by him and became
friends with him and his wife,
as she did with numbers
of her composers.
They became her friends.
And Darius Milhaud has been deceased
for some time, and back in --
after I finished this video, I
started thinking about Mrs. Milhaud
because Cyrilla had mentioned her,
and she was living at the time
and was 97 years old in Paris.
And so, I -- John Newsome
gave -- got a small grant.
It was only $2500 to go -- for me to
go to Paris and shoot an interview
with Mrs. Milhaud while
she was still with us.
So I did that, and she talked
about Mrs. Coolidge and how she
and Darius became acquainted
with her and her impressions
of Mrs. Coolidge and
some stories about her,
and especially how Mrs. Coolidge
enabled them to survive the Nazis
because being a Jewish composer,
he and his wife fled France
after the Occupation of Paris,
made their way down to Lisbon,
and got onto a freighter, and
made their way to New York.
And Mrs. Coolidge got him a job
at Mills College outside
of San Francisco.
So he was able to get a Visa
and work during the War.
So not only did he survive the
War, but he taught other --
his students, and one of
them was Dave Brubeck,
the great jazz composer who just
died recently a couple years ago,
and he was like 99 years old
or something at the time.
Because Darius Milhaud was a --
kind of a [sic] iconoclastic film --
music composer, he wrote music that
had a lot of folkloric elements
and sort of jazz elements.
So -- and also different
musical rhythms --
so when you think of Dave
Brubeck, you think of Take Five,
which had the 5/8 time,
and different mixtures
of time signatures.
But you could sort of -- it's
an interesting connection.
So that was one interview,
and the second one was --
we're going to see over
here in a minute --
Gunther Schuler, the late
Gunther Schuler from Boston.
I don't know.
Has anyone heard of
him, Gunther Schuler?
Yeah? Okay.
Okay. So Gunther Schuler
was, as you know,
a great self-taught
brass music player.
He was actually on the classic
jazz album "The Birth of the Cool",
believe it or not, with Miles Davis.
This is like a classic, you know,
record-breaking jazz recording.
But he also was a composer and a
conductor, and he's been an author,
and he was involved with New
England Conservatory for years.
He was the last living person
to receive a commission
from the Coolidge Foundation.
So back in 1997 I asked him if
he would be on my advisory panel,
which he agreed to do, and then
for the film -- the hour long film,
which hasn't happened yet.
So, I kept in touch with him
and about four years ago,
I thought 'Hey, I get to get back
working on the feature again".
So, then a couple of years
ago, I became very aware
of Gunther's advanced age and I
had this inner voice telling me,
'You've got to get this now'.
So, a year ago February I
went and paid out of pocket
to shot this interview with him.
Hired a videographer and he
just passed away at the end
of June, very, very sadly.
He was in his -- you know, 89
years old and he died of Leukemia.
So, when you see him over
here, he's quite emaciated
and he didn't know -- I don't
know if he knew he was ill
but he knew something was wrong.
He said, "Oh, I don't
know what happened.
I lost 30% of my body
weight and I'm --
all my clothes are
hanging off of me."
But we did capture some of
his thoughts of Mrs. Coolidge,
and I think -- are we
going to look at that know?
>> We're going to play
a couple minute clip
of this interview with
Gunther Schuler.
>> [Inaudible] I think she was
a very positive [inaudible].
She was -- she didn't
want any praise for this,
and I know that on the other side
[inaudible] to look up to her.
I wondered how they
would [inaudible].
I had even seen her at some of
the concerts, including my own,
[inaudible] work that
she commissioned.
I can't even say that
I met her there.
But it could be.
[Inaudible] getting
a little bit full.
But she was -- she did all this
just for the [inaudible] of music
because she was a very good
musician, and what's so remarkable
about her is that -- and we're
talking now about [inaudible].
First of all, there was
not a [inaudible], yes.
There were certain
foundations that --
one foundation famous for publishing
works is the Guggenheim Foundation.
They [inaudible] for me, you know?
And so, now we have so many
publishing [inaudible].
But anyway, what was
so wonderful about her,
she decided to commission
the music [inaudible].
When there are [inaudible],
it was [inaudible],
as if that was the only [inaudible].
And she played so much
chamber music in her career
as a pianist, she [inaudible].
But she said, "Well, [inaudible]."
So that's why she became
the first great commissioner
over [inaudible] years of
chamber music [inaudible]."
>> That's great.
That's great.
She was also one of the
first, if not the first,
important commissioners of dance
music when you look at the dance
that she commissioned, largely from
Martha Graham and Martha Graham --
the Martha Graham companies
going to be back here
at the later part of our season.
But she also commissioned
Stravinsky, Sepal in 1928 was that?
Yeah. So, she was very important
to dance in America as well.
There is a wonderful letter
that Martha Graham wrote
to Mrs. Coolidge that's in
the exhibit where she talks
about how important she is
to American modern dance.
I think we're about ready to
move on into what we weren't able
to include in our exhibit.
So, were going to turn this back
over to Kate and she is going
to talk to you about some of
the things that we brought
to put on display over here.
>> So, adding onto what
Robin said earlier today.
She said that when you're working
on something like an exhibit
or like Margery's film, you are
selecting what stories to tell
and what stories will not get told.
So, one of the fun things
about doing this project
with Robin was the myriad of
stories that could have been told,
so many important commissions,
so many important performances,
etc. Etc. so what we thought we
would do is put together a little
display and we have
done that for you today,
featuring just a couple
of those stories.
So, what I'll do is I'll run
through a couple of those stories
that we did not tell in the exhibit.
And then I think we'll have a little
bit of time for questions for me,
Robin and Margery and we'd
love for you to come up
and take a closer look
at what we've pulled.
So, I'll kind of start at the front
of the table and work my way back.
This is one of my favorite things.
That does show up in the exhibit
but it didn't get quite the emphasis
that we had first imagined.
Oh and let me bring out my.
Okay. So, I'll change
it in a second.
Thanks. The -- we have a collection
called the Prentice Taylor
Collection that I'd never heard
of before I started
working on this project.
And Prentice Taylor was
a DC born artist who went
to the Corcoran, studied there.
He spent some time in New York City
during the Harlem Reissuance era.
He was friends with Carl Vanvectin,
who actually took this photograph.
He was friends with Langston
Hughes and Aaron Copland.
So he had some -- he was friends
with big names in the arts world,
but he was also a regular concert
goer here in Coolidge Auditorium.
He came -- we have a
collection of his programs,
and the ones we've brought out are
largely from the 1940s and '50s.
Where -- the fun thing
about these programs is
that he would actually come
to the concerts and sketch
out the performances
as they were happening,
and because of that we
have this program here.
These are programs that did
make it into the exhibit.
This is actually a program from the
1944 festival were Martha Graham's
dances, including "Appalachian
Spring", were premiered.
And that is actually
on the lower right.
That is his depiction
of "Appalachian Spring".
And above you get Herodias.
It's another Martha Graham ballet.
There is that and my favorite
piece, maybe in the whole exhibit.
This is the back of a program.
So you can't see a
title or anything.
This is actually the premier of
Samuel Barber's Hermit Songs,
and right there is his sketch
of Samuel Barber at the piano
and Lanteen Price [assumed
spelling] premiering the work,
which just makes me smile
every time I walk by it.
But there are plenty of other
programs with similar sketches.
Sometimes he turned them
into more finished works,
and he actual gave some of
his sketches to Mrs. Coolidge.
We have some correspondence were he
expresses how much he loved what her
concerts brought to Washington,
you know, cultural life for him,
and he wrote an article about his
experience coming to these concerts
for an American university
publication.
So, that's one story.
We kind of envisioned including
many more of his programs,
but here you get to see them today.
The second one will stand out at
you if you look over at the tables.
There is a charcoal portrait of Mrs.
Coolidge that was done by none other
than John Singer Sargent.
That is from 1923.
She sought out the work from him.
I was 1923, this was
before she was involved
with the foundation
here at the library.
He said -- She actually
wanted a painting originally.
And he said, "At this point
in my life I'm not really able
to work on a painting like that.
I do offer charcoals now."
And he said -- you know, and he
listed his price, 100 pounds.
She paid him 105 pounds.
We have the correspondence
in the Coolidge Collection,
and it's one of our favorite pieces.
We did not feature
that in the exhibit,
which seems like kind of a go to.
But when you're planning the
exhibit out, it's about so much more
than just what we want
in the exhibit.
You're incorporating a
designer and the, you know,
interpretive program's office
here, who is, you know,
worried about balancing all
the different parts we have.
But that's kind of an
impossible piece not to leave
out of a display on Mrs. Coolidge.
So we're happy to bring
it out today,
and last night we had
it out as well.
Oh, and the other thing I wanted
to say about this and how it fits
into our current exhibit, this
is a letter that if you go
across the street,
you'll see in the exhibit.
This is from Carl Angle.
He was the Chief of the Music
Division when Mrs. Coolidge kind
of came on the scene in
the '20s, and they started
up this partnership
working on commissioning
and taking care of the foundation.
But it really developed into
this wonderful friendship too.
They both had great senses of humor.
They had nicknames for each other,
and one of the nicknames that came
about comes from the slogan
for Michelin Tire Company.
Their slogan was "Il
boit l'obstacles",
French for "It eats obstacles,"
and he said, "You eat obstacles.
I think this describes
you perfectly."
So she would call him Michel,
and he would call her Lina,
so it's kind of this Michelin.
And right here, we have a
letter that he wrote to her,
and he drew a little
portrait of both of them
as little Michelin Men figures.
And next to it, it actually says,
"Almost as good as Sargent."
But you will have no idea what
that means if you just come
to the exhibit because
you don't see the Sargent.
So you get an insider peek at that.
Then on the table, we wanted
to acknowledge today's concert
and the programming of early music.
If you were at the concert
last night, you know,
that celebrated Mrs. Coolidge's
interest in new voices and new work.
But we also acknowledged
before the concert began
that she was very much, you know,
in love with early music too.
In 1925 at the first ever
Festival of Chamber Music, a group,
the English Singers, that
specialized in early English music,
she invited them to come perform.
So we have a signed photography,
which is lovely, next to it.
We have some correspondence,
some telegrams,
kind of making the financial
arrangements for this visit.
We have the check that she wrote
to the English Singers for $998
for a two-week visit to
the States and the program
from that concert as well.
Next to that, I also
included an advertisement
for a lecture series
by Edmond Fellows.
If you don't know Edmond Fellows, he
was a British -- he was a clergyman.
He was a member of the -- or
clergyman for the Church of England,
but he was also a renowned
music scholar,
and his emphasis was early music.
And he often worked with groups
like the English Singers.
In 1927, Elizabeth Sprague
Coolidge invited him to come
and give the first ever musicology
lecture in Coolidge Auditorium,
and that's another story.
I mean we didn't really touch on the
early music interest in our exhibit.
That's kind of another story
that gets overshadowed a lot too,
is that is the contribution she also
made to music scholarship as well.
When Oscar Sonic, another, you know,
early Chief of the Music Division,
when he passed away, he was really
passionate about American music.
And she set up a scholarship
fund for American music research.
So again, another story that
won't come out in the exhibit,
but is worth more exploration,
and Cyrilla Barr has an article
about that -- about
that strain as well.
Then at the very end, we also
included some programs of some
of the concerts that the
foundation did sponsor overseas.
It wasn't just all
happening in Washington,
D.C. She would not have liked that.
She wanted as many
people as possible
to enjoy the benefits
of chamber music.
So that meant going
across the country.
It meant going to France, Germany,
Mexico, et cetera, et cetera.
So we have some of those
on display as well.
Let me check on time.
Okay. So I think we have a few
minutes to open it up for questions.
If anybody has questions for
Marjorie about the film or Robin
or me about the exhibit,
we would be happy to do --
>> [Inaudible] I have
a question [inaudible]
>> I think there's a
mic coming for you.
>> I have a question that's
totally out of ignorance,
but where you informed
about her through diaries
or mostly letters back
and forth over the years?
Who, kind of gathered or made
sure that that was all saved?
Was that her son?
>> Who gathered the collection?
Do you want to speak to that?
>> Once the foundation was
set up here at the library,
there is Coolidge Foundation
papers but her --
Cyrilla Barr, who wrote
Mrs. Coolidge's biography,
worked very closely
with family members.
And in fact after Cyrilla's
biography was published,
Cyrilla gave us additions
to the Coolidge collection.
And so it's --
>> [ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Things that were actually
written by Mrs. Coolidge.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Correspondence is
in the collection.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Hi. I just think that we
should acknowledge that we have
in the audience here two
of Mrs. Coolidge's
great granddaughters,
Peg and Josie Windship.
Who are here.
I hope they're getting an idea
of how revered she is for us.
And I was wondering whether they
wanted to share any reflections
or stories of their own
about their great Grammy.
>> Oh please.
Please.
>> Before that, we
are soaking this up.
It's incredible.
I mean, I just learned
something, Marjorie,
in the film that I had no idea.
So, and I -- thank
you for that question
because I actually
had a similar question
because I know actually my cousin,
another great grandson,
a photographer.
He donated a lot of
photographs, I think.
So, when she gave the commission,
all of her papers were
-- that was part of it.
Granting all of her papers or.
>> Part of the deal with the
foundation commissions was
that the music manuscripts we would
get a copy of the music manuscript
by these composers
in their own hand.
So, those were coming to us
into our collection that way.
That speaks to the music
manuscripts themselves.
>> And her personal
letters, probably.
>> And the correspondence
around the commissions as well.
And a lot of that was
done by the current chief
of the music division at the time.
There is actually.
>> Many avenues.
>> There's actually
related correspondence
in other collections that we have.
>> And more can trickle in from us
because I have an incredible dress.
So, that's got to be
part of it, with silk,
beautiful pink silk
slippers, the whole thing.
It's just amazing.
But I had a question before
giving it to my sister.
Marjorie, how do you want to expand
and hopefully you will
be able to soon?
>> Well, the funding comes first.
Well, hopefully I'll get some --
enough funding to go and shoot
the interview with Cyrilla.
Cause she is quite
elderly now and not
in good health and
living in Wisconsin.
So, I'm just going to be doing --
capturing the interviews with the
important figures including you
family members.
>> I was thinking more thematically.
I mean, yeah.
>> Okay. So, thematically,
I'm just going to be --
put Cyrilla first to gather
everything she's got, you know,
that she can put on video.
And then I'm just going to go
around and use this as a frame work,
my eight and a half minute film.
Do a like a kind of a
strait forward, I think,
chronological telling of the story.
And I have this == I have
outlined specific things I want
to cover in my proposal.
So, this, you know, the basic --
everything that was in
here fleshed out and more.
More stories about, you know,
her life and people that knew her
and her importance as a female,
as a woman patron of music.
Which there are very few and
why she is not more known.
And, yeah, I'm going to just
basically flesh it out, you know.
And I'm trying to think
of what else.
Yeah, that's kind of it.
Yep.
>> And if someone wanted
to contribute to your,
you know, how would they do it?
Do you have a -- would
it be through?
>> Well, I have a -- I'm in
the process of getting a 501c3.
I have a 501c3 organization
for my other music project
but I don't have one for this.
So, I'm in the process
of setting one
up because this would be
considered non-profit funding.
So, for people to get a tax
deduction for a charitable donation,
it has to go through a 501c3.
So, that's in the works.
>> Good. I just wanted to add.
Growing up knowing about this huge
figure, our great grandmother,
what most impressed me was that
coming from you know wealth,
and then going through the tragedy
of all the death she experienced.
Her husband and her
parents and that --
that she set it up and was really
serious about it being free.
That everyone who came
would have, you know.
So that, you know.
I just know -- have always been
impressed and proud that she wanted
to share music with
absolutely anyone,
no matter what their
economic situation.
>> She was also really adamant that
the Coolidge Auditorium be wired
for radio broadcast because she
wanted the concerts to be heard
from everyone's living room.
Yu didn't have to be
here to listen to it
and that was met with opposition.
But she fought for it and she
won and we have a transcript
across the street in the exhibit
of a little speech she gave
on the radio before a radio
broadcast and she said,
"I have two things to say
to all of the, you know,
listeners who've written.
Thank you."
And she says this lovely thing.
She says, "To NBC, I
say, 'I told you so'."
>> The other story we heard
growing up was that she would sit
in the Coolidge Auditorium
with a huge;
I don't know what you would call
it, a trumpet thing to her ear
because she was practically deaf.
You know, then she
would sit in the front.
She was quite a figure
sitting there.
>> One thing that my mother told me,
which I don't know how true it is.
I know Cyrilla touched on it
but which really impressed me.
She actually did not --
my mother said this now,
it needs to be verified.
She really didn't like
contemporary music, Chamber music,
really didn't like it, but
said you have to invest;
you have to support the art form.
And I've heard people say that
she was called the fairy godmother
of chamber music.
I think, I don't know where and
if -- how broadly that was used.
But -- and I was her -- because I
have some of her musician friends,
who were just blown away
by what they played so many
of the compositions she had done
and she really saved chamber music
by supporting the new art form.
>> I'll add two things to that.
At this letter at the
top it says DFQ
and that stands for
Dear Fairy Queen.
And then the other thing about
new music, we include this quote.
It's my favorite quote that
I found in doing the research
and this is included in the
introduction across the street,
but Mrs. Coolidge wrote
and said in a speech once,
'My plan for modern music is
not that we should like it,
not necessarily that we
should even understand it
but that we should exhibit it as
a significant human document'.
I think that's pretty amazing.
>> Yeah, can ask about maybe
addressing you two as well as,
I guess, Greg was your grandfather
than, about the music in the family
and what the legacy of the music
actually, you know, playing and.
>> Yeah. Thanks.
My sister and I play
the guitar and sing
but I grew up folk music and yeah.
I really had no classical
training what so ever.
I grew up hearing it.
My grandfather and his wife, my
grandmother, played quartets all
of the time and would meet
with people, informal quartets.
He -- I was told -- couldn't
judge it at the time.
He was a scientist, a
chemist, at Harvard.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Oh, we'll talk.
>> And he apparently played
like a scientist, very exact.
He was really quite a ridged guy.
I think, you know, another side
of Mrs. Coolidge is she sent him
to a school when he
was really young.
Not sure how much nurturing he
got, I'm sure he was loved but,
you know so, anyway,
that's my memory.
Do you, Joe?
>> Well, I want to
leave a few minutes.
So that you all can come up and
see some of the display up close.
I just want to say thank you to Peg
and Josie Windship for being here.
Thank you to Marjorie
for being here.
Thank you to Robin
for working with me.
And my last thing is please go
see the exhibit across the street.
It's up and until January
23 and then it will go
to LA Walt Disney Concert Hall.
So, if you're in LA you
can go check it out too
but come here while it's here.
So, thank you all.
We'll be by the tables if
you have more questions.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.